à vous de décider maintenant tu es sans
l'europe à la barre des accusés avec le
public comme juré c'est le principe de
ce procès théâtralisée l'union
européenne est visé par plusieurs chefs
d'accusation des nombreux désaccords sur
les modalités de traitement de la crise
migratoire dont il constitue un motif de
rupture du pacte euro vers l'europe
est-elle pénalement responsable de la
situation dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons et j'aimerais
non pas besoin d'être expert
le modèle européen au coeur du débat
entre la procureur et l'avocat de la
défense
cette pièce participatif fait appel à
des experts des questions européennes
pour témoigner ce soir-là à rené pris au
conseiller municipal de saint germain en
laye et fanny du bre experts du cnrs
sont appelés à la barre et sur la craie
en 2014 cette pièce amène à réfléchir
sur l'union européenne à comprendre les
mécanismes et les décisions prises à ce
niveau ainsi certains enjeux des
prochaines élections européennes
apparaissent il me semblait que la
question du débat et aux européens
étaient trop polarisé les pro-européens
les anti européens et que le procès
était au final une très bonne forme pour
amener des nuances et de la
contradiction que pour nous l'enjeu
c'est de faire poser des questions aux
gens et ne pas donner de réponse on
passe notre temps à écouter des réponses
sur l'europe ce qu'elle doit s que de
bois pas être nous ce qu'on veut c'est
réinterroger sur l'europe et l'exigence
réintéresse à ce sujet qui nous paraît
primordial autre enjeu du scrutin la
participation notamment des jeunes le
député européen jean marie cavada
mobilise les lycéens en tenant des
conférences
c'est le cas du lycée marie curie à
versailles avec des élèves conscients
des enjeux européens
si si jamais les élections stopper la
construction de l'europe par le fait que
des anti européens soit majoritaire au
pouvoir
alors comment serait un des siècles d
des décennies en tout cas extrêmement
pénibles ou notion de petit pays à la
merci des grands et c'est ça que je ne
veux pas pointer un enjeu social pour le
bien-être des gens l'évolution des
populations européennes et aussi pour
l'environnement qui va ne le cachons pas
très mal aujourd'hui j'ai une crainte
que l'on que l' influence du moment
vienne sur la sur l'union européenne
donc c'est pour ça que je pense que le
scrutin est important en ce moment est
aussi sur la raisons climatiques est
aussi extrêmement importante c'est parce
que c'est le monde de demain
enfin ce scrutin aura un enjeu national
c'est la première élection depuis le
début du mandat d' emmanuel macron cette
échéance électorale dégagera un
enseignement politique dans un contexte
de contestation sociale menée par le
mouvement des gilet jaune